have you been starstruck working with
certain people bernie mac
yes bernie
i was star struck you were i was star
struck with bernie because
i couldn't believe how
generous he was
he was so sweet to me
so nice
no one nicer man
what do you remember
oh [ __ ]
funny [ __ ]
go ahead go ahead bruh do do whatever
you want to do go ahead you know this is
the bernie mac show
please
whatever you do is going to make the
show funny
please
do go ahead bruh he was so cool with me
i felt bernie mac was here for a second
well i really did name jingling
yeah
i'm scared of you [ __ ]
he was so and now i was like if i ever
get to be a number one on a call sheet
that's who i want to be
because he's
it's the bernie mac show so i whatever i
do i'm a guest star i'm building that's
what he was saying you you're helping me
my show
so please go go
be as funny as you possibly can and that
was
so eye-opening for me wow that was so
that isn't you don't always see that
with lead actors i have worked with lead
actors i know you have
you don't want to mention any by name
but you've worked with some people that
you were like yeah i'm not that's not a
role model right that's not who i want
to be no
bernie
cedric the entertainer they're like uh
they come from those schools of
oh i'ma get my i'm gonna get my shots up
you know
go ahead yeah please
get in here scotty pippin and you know
knocks them out too please
help me yeah help me win this
championship i'm i got it you know i but
whatever you can bring
is is really beneficial and
you know those are the that's the type
of dude i want to be you know if uh and
i've always been you know please
uh bring whatever you can here right
but you just wanted to impress him you
wanted to make him laugh
yeah
and i had a point of view you know from
my improv and you know theater training
and i felt like the character should be
this
and
you know i just trusted my instincts but
having someone like that say yeah go
was all i needed you know sometimes you
need someone to say yes
yes you know
someone you just need that like yeah
dude yeah that well we all know we don't
yeah we all need that whatever it is
like hey this is this is great let's go
get going let's go with this but that's
why i also like improv because it is
that you know
you